have you guys heard um the stat that one
in five women have been
i don't know if we can say i'll say s
aid or grape um on
either one and five or one and three
have been
graped on college campuses have you
heard that no
i think that's weird i think i heard it
like back in the day like back in the
day around that statistic yeah yeah i
think i heard it like back when that um
that thing happened with that boy that
grape the girl and what was his name the
blonde dude
anyways oh i know who you're talking
about in that documentary um yeah the
chat will tell me if it was one and five
or one and three hold on let me know in
the chat which one sorry you so you've
heard it you've heard it no i feel like
i've heard something along the lines
is that
that is that that statistic is from the
states right
is that something that one on five
happens
in
in the uk at all i'm not saying that it
doesn't but is it i don't feel like it
would be the same because i feel like
the college culture in the us is so
different to how it is in the uk
well the what my point was actually that
that stat isn't correct so they've been
misquoting that stat for years wow and
giving because if if one in five women
were getting graped on college campuses
you think your dad would send you to
college
it's like a war zone yeah they they
included if you hooked up with someone
while drunk
oh
so even if the guy was drunk too it's
still
great
in that study
so like you both could be
or if you felt pressured so if a guy's
like pressuring you to sleep with him
and you still chose to like you could
count that as grape
so you're asking girls have you ever had
sex drunk
or been pressured to have sex and did it
so i think one in five women would say
yes to that
but that's a completely different thing
than like grape
yeah
so um my question is why
why do you think they like pushed that
stat even though it was so inaccurate
well i'll give you my opinion i think it
was part of an agenda um an agenda in a
sense to kind of push a narrative that
wasn't necessarily true and they didn't
really have hard facts so what they
would have done is they would have
encompassed different parts of a
statistic in order to prove a point
and whether it was true or not um it
kind of gets their agenda pushed out
there and then people that are ready to
bandwagon will jump on it without even
knowing the
nitty gritty details of
what actually happened
or maybe it just it would it was in a
favor of a situation maybe like just to
consolidate a situation that happened
maybe they just brought that
start out
if that makes sense do you think the
people that push that stat should be
held accountable for it
for like misquoting like very very odd
like we would agree that that's that's a
poor way to portray it right we would
like i think we'd all agree that
drunk drunk sex
and sex that someone pressured you into
it's not the same thing as getting
pulled into a park or something and held
down and like against like those are two
different things yeah yeah so do you
think that the people that pushed those
stats
and ran campaigns on those stats should
be held accountable yeah 100 i mean just
imagine parents responsible because
you're essentially
running a campaign and
doing all this stuff on a lie
and you're not
you're not positively benefiting anybody
because it's a it's a lie and in the end
when all
if it comes back that this stat was a
lie from the beginning and you have to
go back through all this stuff and every
person that was
in your campaign you have to go back and
like prove now was this truth or this a
lie so it's like very nitpicky if you
lie from the beginning and you have all
these years of lying you gotta somehow
either
go back and be like um this is actually
the truth and like explain every single
situation to be truthful or you just
sweep it up under the rug and be like
it's okay
do you think that
it it created fear of men
like pushing that stat
like for for women like do you feel like
it made it kind of played into the men
or trash
narrative yeah of course it has to be
like just imagine young girls deciding
to go to college what would they think
about it knowing that reading that
statement would make them a bit
like scared of it right i'm talking from
my experience as an international
student if i go for example if i decide
going to college at 18 years old and i i
hear this
i would be scared 100
like
because um it's not something that we
should take lightly especially just
imagine families reason that your
parents you're maybe the the only girl
in the family and they're sending you a
bro to study and they're reading that
what would they feel about it they will
it's not even you who would be fear
enough men they will actually put that
fear in you that see you shouldn't be
doing this men can be trash like that
man can do this to you don't go out late
at night blah blah blah blah so it can
be cultivated in you as well from family
just by hearing them so it's definitely
wrong and they should be accountable for
it
do you think that women that falsely
accuse men
should go to prison
yes about grape yes yeah definitely
speak into the mic please
i would say
it's a tough one yeah i mean
oh i would i will say it
i would base it depending on how damn it
yeah on the damage that it had on the
guy so said like if he had like this
huge career and like that all sort of
like you know was ruined on the base of
that um then i would say yes
but if it was like just some guy and
like it nothing really happened like i
would say
but what about reputation like everyone
on so if a girl does that on campus even
if say say there's no job no he's still
in school whatever
everyone looks at him like can you
imagine walking into a room and having
everyone think you did that yeah and
just because one girl got mad because
you dumped her
yeah
i don't think it should be based on
their
status because
either way if they're this high value
person or they're just some joe schmo
off the street it affects them from
someone negatively saying that they
raped him like that's life-changing and
altering and
it's even worse for someone who cannot
defend themselves in court who can't
afford to defend themselves not saying
that the one that has money it's
easier for them because it's still
detrimental both ways but i i think that
if you lie on someone
in that type of situation you
you should automatically be
penalized for it yeah yeah whether
that's in jail or not but there has to
be some sort of repercussion yeah yeah
definitely
you should you should pay the
consequences of every action that you do
and if you do that i think
of course if you are a woman or a man
you should pay the consequences it
doesn't for me
a lot of subjects that you talk pearl
it's not for me i don't think as a
gender i think as a as people you know
we are all people we are you know all
sinners in a way nobody is a saint in
the end of the day we are all humans we
do mistakes there's other there's good
people there's bad people we are
sometimes we meet good people and they
get worse and there's sometimes we met
worse people and then after a few years
they get better so it's not about gender
in the end of the day you know um
they're of course biologically as women
and men we are different and when it
comes with privilege
how you say privilege privilege and
conditions and all that yeah it changes
but
when it comes you know to consequences
and all that yeah definitely i mean goes
for both ways well i think that the
point um i because i never say like i
think people are shitty like in general
like i think there's a lot of shitty
people and i think there's oh yeah and
shitty women but the point is that when
when men are shitty there's almost
always a consequence
when women are shitty there oftentimes
is not
because women can hit men in public and
no one really does anything
women can falsely accuse someone and
she's not going to jail she's getting
sued
when she ruined that man's livelihood
the last five years
like women can
there is a there's
another issue which is like father's
rights too like there's a woman in the
u.s who gave her kid up for adoption and
the dad wanted to be in his life
and the dad like wanted the kid and she
could legally give that kid up for
adoption because she was a woman because
that was in the u.s yeah but i i would
but who did that rule i would guess that
rule a woman
i mean that would loan that law a woman
or a man well i think the law um i don't
know i don't know we have to think about
that
it could be men passing this these laws
but that's not the point the point is
that the justice system and i would
guess it's similar here i don't i don't
know the uk but i would guess it's
similar here because where a gynocentric
social order is everywhere
and and
in custody cases
like a a woman has to be a terrible
mother to lose the kid the like the the
woman almost always gets it
when it should it should just be 50 50.
and if and then a girl can also
sleep with a guy get a kid out of him
like like trap a guy
and if she doesn't want the kid she can
have an abortion but if the man doesn't
want like to be a part of his life he
can't do anything he has no choice what
do you mean the woman trapped the guy
and then she doesn't i i do understand
what are you saying drake the drake
incident where the girl was taking the
condom and putting hot like like he put
the hot sauce in it uh yeah so like
women can do things like that and if if
he caught her doing that that means
other girls have done it and so they've
done that yeah because because that's
that's the thing if something comes to
the forefront that means in society it's
been happening
so girls can can trap a guy or tell him
he's on birth control get a kid out of
him and force that man to pay child
support for 18 years and girls will
cheer each other on to do this
they'll cheer yeah on social media like
get that bag get that check
yes
no no that's that's another way to get
that back no like what the hell what are
you getting for brittany renner she said
if you really want to catch a check you
go sleep with an nba player because they
don't use condoms oh no because she's
the one that had the babies
yeah yeah yeah yeah and that's like
like and nobody there was no outrage no
nothing and so now that man's on the
hook for child support like i don't
understand why we even have child
support you're a girl you can work like
what the
is there something stopping you from
working yeah like so we have and and on
top of that there's there's laws where
men are stuck in child support like if a
man loses his job he still has to pay
child support even if he can't afford it
and they're they're gonna pay then
he goes to jail yeah if he doesn't
like that so he's not even able to
or men men don't have access to their
children because they just give him to
the mother and they'll go to court for
years
fighting like like trying to be a part
of the kid's life and they just can't
because the judgmental system is so
skewed what kind of dumb woman trapped a
man that he's broke and tried to get the
child out of him well the point is he
might not have been broke to start so
let's say if a guy was making six
figures makes sense and she says you
have to pay 50 of your income or 25
let's say 25 percent of your income has
to go to the mother of your kids
yeah of a month then he loses his job
he can't pay it yeah so now what
now he's got child support payment
payment payment payment and
it's like it this ruins men's livelihood
so like the whole point of my show isn't
necessarily to say because i could go on
and on about the like the shitty things
men there there are some shitty toxic
madness talk about that yeah they keep
spouting but the thing is we do like in
every other media source we always talk
about the men
all the time